yeah hello and welcome to our Monday
nights just explained show let's get
going with some 5-minute games and I
have to say I've completely wrecked my
rating yeah played some games last week
it wasn't good so game started I really
have to come back they have two or three
twenty-seven that it doesn't look good
so yen the man let's go d4 yeah Jim I
don't feel very experimental
I feel like winning games let's see what
yen the man is doing it's playing a neo
filly to him transposing from d4
but yeah I'm generally happy with this
age 5 ok I have played them quite a bit
usually having very nice positions but
then doing something stupid losing on
time and I hope we don't get this year
as well this position already looks
excellent for white black has absolutely
no space so what's the deal
f4 mm yeah let's pry this open yeah I
kind of expected that but it should be
nice for what I got so much space him
[Music]
and he has a hard time to ever Castle
how is he cancelling in this tradition
canceling wrong maybe
d5 is even interesting him I think I'll
go d5 here he cannot bring the bishop to
occupy me five so d5 should be good also
makes long castling a difficult
proposition okay yeah if five looks like
complete disaster he takes it I go d6
yeah hope I can do something good damn I
mean this rating is pretty terrible also
I have to say quite terrible for the
opponent's usually I'm just like 100
points higher no I cannot take a call
him how do I actually kill this off
[Music]
sorry about that this guy is really
resilient Jim I'm not going to take this
call
how do i how do I stop that actually
okay so we have to differ that hopefully
not for one hour okay so if it takes it
I'm going to play these six and now so
you can still castle but what to do
95 maybe Quinta ji for something that
still is is in in this position somehow
maybe I just mmm but if I take only five
he has all kinds of things 94 maybe
thirty nine ninety five but it's not
that clear
mm-hmm but so it's the cleanest way here
maybe still Bishop takes you five I mean
now it's probably right
and now just move the bishop again I
mean why not I'm threatening three takes
aged five and if you play screen before
I'm going to take that and that position
cannot be okay for like which is a very
friendly way to put it but if I take
aged five this is also a disaster so
just she can take this but take aged
five yes Queen to e3 yourself I probably
want to take an ending this is just just
bad
even though to be a little bit on the
lookout here that I'm not allowing too
much like if five and the King would
approach this is something that is it's
not not not that clear actually yeah
this isn't this isn't so easy if five
and post potentially bringing the King
up and I shouldn't have traded Queens
probably huh
I shouldn't have traded Queens amazing
that's that's it surprising okay can go
together three but I will go D seven so
let's go would you say I did would be
Bishop d6 now and then take on c5 so
it's stopping that
before I meet he does not work night if
age is probably coming
it's not easy here absolutely not
time warning yeah I know but I'm also
not that happy with all this it was a
fantastic position before and now I've
really squandered lots of it
way ambitious maybe good also shoots 967
I had 93 okay he defended this well I
mean I played it terribly it was just a
winning position at one point very bad
by me
hey shouldn't trader Lucas yeah I think
still not easy for him his pieces are
still bad I mean it started out with a
position where black was basically toast
and know I wanted to play b3 of course I
know he got Mouse lips on him
great great stuff yeah check yeah that
was a silver plate game them gifting the
game basically the whole of the opening
position was just raw Alfred what's just
Mike Morrison lost for luck
yeah the Queen trade was bad yeah I mean
here black is just toast but I should
not trade Queens on his exam this is
just very bad that gives him the frm I
can just play play something like that
and have fantastic control very bad okay
started I mean there's a reason why I
had a happy not in good shape last week
I don't know what it what's going on to
315 of to 314 is really terrible
so just kids who's playing the London
system and get a fairly normal position
yeah it's a little bit unusual this this
thing with 93-94 but I think it's it
leads to interesting play it's a little
bit more interesting than many other
typical London setups typical ready
position now we are not sure that the
night on c4 is all that great
Bishop f3 really
how lame is that
I don't know does he want to play you
form okay I'm doing something on the
queenside just to make things a bit more
interesting so knight c6 is 96 is
possibly on so I'm covering that
you
what defines already set up and yo
basically the double fianchetto from the
black sodium double fianchetto and then
c v b6 these successes already set up
from the from the white side the other
would be from Knight f3 d5 c4
hmm so he tries to occupy c6 mm mm
interesting it's a direct threat
don't know how dangerous that is maybe
he wants to go inform don't know my
ideas to play see 495 the bad thing is
are not getting rid of this night
soonish which i could do i can play
night ba but okay now it seems that if i
was what he wants to do I could play e5
myself actually let's do that
all of a sudden if he does not take it
looks a lot like some kind of some kind
of Spanish opening some window pass
so okay Knight b8 blunders the night
[Music]
yeah 97 Czechia is annoying here he
removed the night
[Music]
we not sure
what he takes it
ha I've never expected that move maybe
it's good though I mean it's possible
I'm not sure though might be three
that's a that many nights here
many nights around but I have a hard
time to believe that this is good friend
and those nights stranded I mean
currently I were taking the full book so
he has to basically take on b7 or not I
think he has to write always does he
have any miracle tactic here the look is
completely hanging not before something
known so I'm taking here no night has to
go back to a5 I guess now here are now
threatening look ahead name is he the
Knights now are somewhat stranded
I wasn't sure how bad that really was I
know that looks the knight on c6 looks
looks strong but it's not that clear
it's often not that clear
so here 93 he wants to go edge for here
but ok maybe I can just still play group
here the Knights have really they have
no squares this I don't see squares at
the moment why is he just going crazy
here he is going crazy
okay okay look he can go to c8 at the
end but I don't that this position is
fairly no didn't see that one correctly
to go here now how to do that
Queen a7 does threaten some discoveries
there a way to check as Queen d7
this is threatened yeah I am this is
right oh it doesn't react to it time
warning check
so this should have four or night if six
was my original idea
Queen is six I wanted to go Queen III
now but maybe yes look I have six
awesome sums you know Queen f7 oh my god
okay Queen d7 does rook f6 shoot it's
not ideal and I only have 15 seconds
check check check check check check
check check check check check check
check check that's a question but then
I'm just wondering if it's a good idea
to take a complete break from chess
before a tournament to improve my
results and what you definitely should
do like right before the tournament like
a week or so definitely reduce the
workload yeah I don't do don't do
without a couple of hours a day yeah
that's not a good idea try to relax a
bit and start it and then
then play the tournament so teams I have
to beat your chicken now why didn't we
do any anything there he was just
completely lost
I just lost some time but I wasn't
trouble before so hard the same yeah
what about this can i play like that
with h4 h5 we'll see
age five is probably a little bit too
swashbuckling but it's kind of its kind
of threatening route Knight takes I go
group takes h5 that works so it's
basically saying I'm threatening nothing
here that is possible it really is
possible check and now is thinking
that's funny if I need somehow and okay
so night to defy them that's the thing
an IT FOIA
I should have considered 94 yeah my
rating is below 2300 which is really not
good but normally at this is the point
where it takes to the takes a spike
upwards yeah so night you form doesn't
do all that much he's got this check
this is the thing is there anything else
that I can do
Bishop age three maybe I'm not sure if
this is really threatening much did you
check yeah this is possible now maybe
Bishop Bishop e6 as an idea here in this
position so we took it and Queen takes
he can play Queen d7
hmm goodnight is six not sure if that
really Nets much but I'm still I'm still
going for it
yeah I don't quite see what I'm
threatening after same okay I threatened
to take the route but it's um like rook
f7 I don't have a fantastic continuation
them it's going to play well or c5 and
96
he takes Knight takes Knight a 492 g6 is
an idea I currently don't see how he
gets rid of the knight so easily 95 97
maybe
Labatt's it's not it's not entirely
clear really isn't and okay so Knight f4
night except to
hmm I mean I can play Ruge f1 and just
cover that
but tonight c5 is probably coming can
then somehow I'll play with about that
can i play with sacrifice mm-hmm
don't quite see how that should work I
don't think it does
that's a very lame move really but I
didn't see anything great night sir five
maybe no he's playing maliciously yeah
night eg6 I'm not sure I mean again
maybe like I take it and he ignores it
yeah that's what he wants to do it seems
but I'm yeah I kind of have to know
everything else is a joke so let's take
it and now so if I go clean to g4 this
is not meeting unfortunately but still
hey I think Knight takes c6 or is he
going for some counter-attack maybe a
blessed win a four and I'm chick made it
possible I know I have queen g4 that
actually does work and this is also a
threat Queen g4 teenage 896 winning huh
why isn't that not winning check that's
winning check check it's not winning
again okay check so with this one I have
to play right check okay check black
resigns oh okay so I got above 2,300
again on the expense of your shake I
could have done that in any event I
should have I can actually play 95 here
already gained cheering so Petey Capri
need to start the meter this is really
blitzes a is a game of four streaks yeah
you sometimes just get a couple of wins
in and then everything seems nice
[Music]
yet I've played him a number of times I
think even last week and back then I've
wondered and blundered to a pawn or
something I remember it was something
weird yeah I did blunder the air horn
with some tactic I don't remember what
tactic
it was exactly but I felt very silly
that's what I remember
[Music]
it's going 23 Oh what is he doing here
um I would definitely like to play
Bishop bees before maybe
Oh
[Music]
hmm that's very annoying huh oh that's
that I have to do that I absolutely had
to prevent I think I played this badly
Oh terrible position what did I do wrong
I have to look at this line again I
really consider to be harmless with b6 I
don't don't believe that this can
endanger black but definitely it can if
it is played in the way I played it here
that really was no good for me
yeah last week I had a lost position
then a winning position and it was was
crazy and I have again I have a very bad
position you know losing is probably the
fair way to call it I need to get
something going here
am I getting McQueen trapped here or
something even hook cheeks is an option
where it is an option try to win d5
maybe it's best got before again or
something there's about five mmm
the c8 Bishop is unprotected it's there
any way to spice up the exchange Slav
I like ideas with Knight h5 Ernie ecigs
not h5 I'm not sure that you can call it
spice it up but at least this is a
little bit interesting I believe but
generally wine is of course extremely
solid in the exchange Slav it's not the
kind of line where you can expect
something fantastic to happen to you
with black it's not so easy and whites
position too plain I mean I'm not in
great shape or anything but she still
has to play well so what is he doing
here doing nc7 this looks kind of normal
let's do it
should be three I can take B - then why
can I not take this and - no yeah kinga
should be five now which she might SEC
but only five which I don't know if
that's good
okay so g4 is movement probably no he
takes that huh so but c3 no can check in
23 maybe check with the head don't have
a just on the clock I wonder if he can
play for an attack on the King simply
yeah that's what he does
Bishop takes h3 I take myself I hope he
will play chicken tikka on e7 is the
thing
time warning I don't know I cannot
calculate this stuff this shoot
that's strong of course ah I hate to
lose this game
laughter I've gotten back injured but I
will black resigned Chuck I don't know
one that okay for me I cannot believe
I'm worse him yeah it was very
complicated and I think it probably did
this right this is practically
practically very very difficult a plane
where the engine doesn't like my
position here but II six no then it's
got like an e6 cannot be right that just
gives away the dark squares completely
yeah okay let's go play games not
analyzed too much but my opening
position was bad I really have to have
to see that I could that in the future
why should not get such a good position
out of the open game started okay anyway
I have to beat making no sense there's
absolutely no alternative to that if you
lose against 2100 something is
completely wrong okay the Rossum that's
uncommon but I don't know the theory and
I'm going to play it safe so he's saying
he does not need a king position okay of
course you can argue that you don't need
one but I still feel I mean way it's
like going to put his King on the Queen
side
so night you find I mean I think I can
ever a couple offer you a useful moves
but I can play and then decide on a plan
so let's put this on d5
I could have I don't know if I even need
a Roxy one I probably could have done
that one move earlier let's see what he
does I mean he has to capture something
I believe Bishop d7 Knight f5 looks
impossible to to stand probably Bishop
t5 okay so is it taking deform which I
cannot cover it doesn't necessarily mean
all that much but okay I have to open
this up
it's still a Snow King position but how
should you add yeah I wonder about a
fire or something like that
hmm I don't see something really good
it's kind of a I don't know what did you
move maybe I'm going look anyone here or
something
it also not so easy for him because well
what is he doing it with a king end and
Luke on a jade really unsure now I can
move it again but Bishop c4 is all of a
sudden coming maybe I can play with
Knight f5 actually this is interesting
yeah let's do it that night f5 is an
interesting idea I didn't see that
before yeah it opens opens it up very
good idea maybe and that's the moment
where you you see it it's your blood
that everything he just canceled
they's defending that well why does he
do that why does it defend well it's not
fair Queen g5 it's the point I mean he
has this King issue so what is he doing
now some big a counter-attack maybe but
I don't see Luke c2 or something like
that I wonder if I should play like f6
since important point here
I can almost take that it let's graph
this point first
name maybe it takes bit yeah
maybe there just takes it so what's the
deal I think I need to I need this
bishop penis somehow we should page six
coming
need all the possible pieces in the
attack
so lot easy fun to play this pusher age
six I don't know what that three
threatening all that much
I think if it feels like he thought it
to threaten activating the Queen how do
I get more pressure against these
Queenie towards a double attack but it's
got Bishop f6 g5 doesn't do much maybe I
go back simply oh no it's got to check
on c4 it's got to check on bloody thief
[Music]
check time warning so what you do here
Bishop g7 doesn't have closer though I
can take f5 here actually I have g4 I
didn't see that beforehand it's a bit
lucky Queen f3 oh we saw that screen of
three which she didn't see should have
taken his 7 I'm such a [ __ ] why didn't
I take that check I don't care each part
is quick enough black resigned Wow then
I was tensed Illya really tense
whoo okay so let's go for new game
really nope wait times that's a good
thing about their championship being
over you have more more people and
there's no no other big event
currently sometimes you have huge open
tournament say that sort of them all the
players occupied yeah still not
not very stable him yeah I've got a
request for game out but I don't get one
yet I need to check this one against
this PG copy PT Capri person the night
on b6 is annoying and it should be
possible to prevent that game started so
ja frog let's see what we can do in the
Sicilian okay
he absolutely seems he wants to play the
maracas see so I can I cannot refuse
this request let's say I really cannot
counter off their disposition on the
board pretty yet the deaths the London
chess classic that's true yeah they also
have this open event forgot about that
why you see if they can you you have to
trade Queens
yeah white is slightly better in this
position but it is not a lot black can
play yeah this is no good I think but
black black black has other ideas I
think this should be better for white we
should be doing maybe I can also check
with the pawn that's not bad probably
yeah it should be true hmm it still kind
of okay for him problem
yeah that is really on but if I take
Jenni I don't have much else come on
let's play it and be quick about it I
was thinking we should a three that I
thought before is good but maybe I'm
wrong
check okay King D 395 you don't want
that but she I felt is so interesting he
cannot easily move the pawns here and
this should be a bit better early
check yeah here I should be a bit better
let's see a 3 B 4 King 2 B 3 and a 4
would be great if I can get it in yeah
Susu pretending it's a good ending a 3
he cannot go before as a 6 is hanging I
am mmm that I should have thought about
prevents a form
after before in particular
[Music]
is there any way forward that's very
difficult I have an idea Bishop d2 my a
four takes be farm and then take a six
check
it looks extremely strange can I do it
now already like a four takes before
Bishop III sorry Bishop c3 he's got a
five I have to do this first
he's got the King now coming coming over
yeah maybe this is far too risky but I
don't want to draw him by doing nothing
[Music]
after taking a 6s we should be 5 to 8
which is very important so I'm taking
this now he's playing this correctly
that 5 is interesting so maybe go back
Bishop g5 now is an idea yeah pawn takes
Knight I can take g6 and the age 5 is
also week it's got chicks there and
she's really down I don't know
every action
check
can basically repeat them but wants to
repeat it really was better
it's got extremely active King yeah I
mean I can sometimes take a for every
five or so it looks strange but he takes
a long time to make up his mind
you know let's take this continue to
take this now see if I can take a form I
can actually win this
it's not easy here - to get to that
bloody night game yeah I'm probably
losing the b-pawn is still somewhat
dangerous but that that won't be enough
I don't know not really in good shape
him that ending should be quite nice for
white maybe you have the immediate aim
for suggested by the engine something
like that must be better for me and I
think I just squander too much time game
started ok one more game junior POV or
junior puffs ok so what do we have
yeah yeah of course and [ __ ] I mean I
would always win this position on time
but that was not the goal
and that's not very exciting check
unfortunately yeah this is a cop-out
choice that white can can take in this
variation just extremely equal the
Italian game sometimes is really not
that exciting
do you hoop takes D to with the threat
but it's not exactly difficult to
prevent three like whatever works okay
so can I have double on the default 9c
force maybe on him
yeah maybe that helps him a little bit
but I want to get his six year for the
King mix makes things a bit easier now I
didn't really follow the open in the
London chest classic it's a fairly
strong event that much a saw but I did
not check results or anything yeah it's
not much Sam Williams and John
Bartholomew were playing John is
certainly trying for his GM knowing that
he wants to play I honestly think that
this tournament is not very well suited
to do that but maybe he will do it
anyway I don't know I don't think he
started particularly well someone said
so it will be difficult to do oh it's
annoying really
yeah I mean and it's not much going on I
think but I cannot remove this bishop
now
it's typical Italian game excitement
check ok anyway it's it's also a draw
after the the rook trade but check check
yeah it's probably I shouldn't do that
it should just make it draw I guess but
it's kind of silly to try to do anything
here with black if anybody mean White
has the more active rook
can only hope that he does something
which is incorrect
grah offered check game wrong yeah that
was very very lame
yeah it's sometimes difficult in those
openings if you play a classical opening
and they play and stuff like that you
don't really do much but that that
applies to many situations I mean even
if black wasn't much stronger player and
then I am it's very difficult to do much
there yeah ok I hope I'm in better shape
next week that wasn't great I'm simply
not in good in a good condition I don't
know thanks for watching guys I'll be
back next week that would be Monday 19th
and this will be the final show for this
year I won't do anything over Christmas
so I hope you all join in next week bye
bye for today